Half off must be a deal, right?
But what if we told you it's not just about the number, it's about the story behind it.
Let's break down how ads, perception and pricing strategy play mind games.
And how smart companies adjust based on how we think.
Not all ads are equal.
Some promotions draw your eye right to the price.
Suddenly you're focused on cost above all else, and demand becomes more elastic.
That means if the price isn't right, people bounce.
So when an ad emphasizes price, the price better be good.
And in this case, when you become more elastic, you want to lower the price on that good.
But some ads go deeper.
They tell stories, they stir emotion.
These ads don't just grab your attention, they increase your willingness to pay.
You become less price sensitive, and that is inelastic demand.
When done right, you can charge more, raise prices, and people feel good about it.
But there's a catch.
Promote too much and customers start waiting for the next sell.  Full price.
No thanks.
They've seen better.
You've trained your shoppers to see regular price as a rip off.
And once that perception sets in, it's hard to win them back.
Want to change how people feel about price?
Reframe it.
Let's say you're buying a pair of premium headphones.
The tax says $150, okay?
Now imagine it says you save $50 instead.
Same price, totally different reaction.  Why?
Because shoppers don't calculate.
They compare.
Framing a deal as a gain taps into the psychology of wins.
And people love feeling like they got the upper hand.
Behavioral economist Richard Tyler breaks it down.
Acquisition utility is what the product's worth to you.
Transaction utility is how the deal feels.
Promotion might not change the product, but they massively boost the second kind of happiness.
So, yeah, promos sell products, but more than that, they shape perception, understand elasticity, frame your value, design your pricing to speak to how people buy, not just what they buy.
That's the real promo power.